[Music]
hey everybody welcome to black man
beyond my name is mark gruhn Arden this
is my fancy ass [ __ ] gopher thank you
so much for coming in and filling in the
last moment right yeah Trisha is fine
everybody all is well her cats all 400
of them like a minor surgery thing but
she was like I'm gonna be crazy [ __ ]
loopy like you're gonna be high no yeah
you should maybe like lay down so you
don't fall down and she's real tall so
that's a long way to fall it's a whole
thing and actually I feel better today
because she always makes me wharfs me
every time let's talk about dumb [ __ ]
today smiles at you real pretty in
Canadian Mike I know and I got good tell
I remember I I got a new car not so long
ago I got a Mustang right and so I drive
it up to Trish's house and she said oh
you got a Mustang did you get the big
500 cylinder and I said no i got the the
EcoBoost and the look on her face dude
she like i've never felt quite so
emasculated what she's like you seen the
giant motorcycles having the garage and
the Porsches that I drove construction
on my house and the guy today was like
why doesn't your boyfriend Drive these
motorcycles and I was like cuz they're
mine do this he was like oh copy that
okay so you and I have we've met three
times I saw this tweet yeah and I was
wracking my brain
I know take a while do it yeah the third
time not expensive it's from H&M you can
throw it
actually it's Topshop it's a little bit
yeah well about more chances [ __ ] the
third time was an Oscar party that bad
robot through like with like Irish
alliance of whatever oh yeah and Mike
we're Liz ago hey we just did a podcast
together look oh hey I remember and you
were super sweet for not remembering who
I was for like you know any like the
second time was doing the podcast at
your house which was lovely and one it
was the third episode of the Battlestar
Galactica we never done we did the first
two with Trish's house where I almost
died because I didn't realize how much
dander was like in her place and I'm
like crazy allergic to that [ __ ] I'm
allergic to cats ooh yeah so like I sit
there in a little kitchen table and I
start going in suddenly and like just
the wheezing begins and like the tears
start to roll like I just I mean yeah
and I could almost died you can hear me
almost done the emotion about my eyes up
and like constricted my chest but the
first time we met was I want to say it
was like 2007 2008 I was moderating I
was working for Entertainment Weekly and
I was moderating a panel at San Diego
comic-con in ballroom 20 my first big
ass [ __ ] panel so I asked me would
you do the women of Battlestar panel and
I said oh I did had a purple dress on
and yellow shoes
I remember the shoes I remember the
shoes and so like because I was there I
was the Battlestar dude that eww like I
was the one who watched the first season
box set and like evangelized about it
was like guys we got a cover this
[ __ ] show like for real you know you
got to cover it and what seal the deal
was I was watching the beginning of
season 2 and Stephen King was a
columnist for The Magazine and he
decided to like drop in and visit us one
day didn't tell anybody and so I'm
sitting in my office watching Battlestar
and I look over my shoulder and Stephen
[ __ ] King is standing in my doorway
and
has been for like ten minutes and just
like I looked over was like oh hey
Stephen King's like hey I love this show
like I know right and he stayed for like
an another ten minutes to keep watching
and then what about his merry way and
skynyrd children somewhere but like I I
advocated to put on the cover like I was
the guy who recapped it like I was I was
the all-in guy so sci-fi is that you
want to moderate a panel I said yes what
is it women a battle store down to show
up and do this work and so I go in the
bin the green room and they introduce me
around it's like oh hi this is Katie hey
oh this is Trisha hey this is like okay
what we're gonna do now is for the third
season we're bringing Lucy Lawless on as
a cast member like she'd been in there
have season of season two and she's were
making full-on I remember the cast so
Kenny we're gonna make a surprise like
front of 6,000 people like it's [ __ ]
Lucy Lawless she's joining the show so
my job was we're gonna introduce her and
say hey Trisha what was it like to share
Baltar with another woman and then she
would answer and then Lucy would come
out and say he's mine you know thing
that sounds Australian or New Zealand it
I used to know it's Australia now yeah I
just end up doing like take it in court
[Laughter]
need to tell me you had a very intimate
relationship with that hammer and when
it left you were destroyed emotionally
and so I'm like okay I got it what was
it like to share Balter with another
woman I got it I got it so we're walking
to the stage right and the promise is
Lana Kim you're so sweet Lana Kim walks
over says okay you got it
great what was it like to share Balter
with another man I got it and so I get
out there on stage in front of all those
people and I say hey Tricia so what was
it like to share Baltar with another man
and like Lucy comes out like hot as a
pistol and Trish is like I'm not a man
she's not a man you're an [ __ ] and I
like that moment is somewhere on YouTube
I think of me just like oh it's over
like I just know I've never experienced
this level of shame but you can't forget
it I can never forget it during the
pilot about Oh sir Galactica there was
this one line I had to say hmm and I
couldn't get it out of my mouth and I
had never done sci-fi before and this
was like the first job I had where I
wasn't like the annoying blonde that
died and you were happy she did so I was
so excited and like I was in a plane and
it was like this is gonna be awesome and
I couldn't get out of my mouth and they
I thought they're gonna fire me I had to
tape my lines to my radiates radius my
rate my latest but that greatest thing
thank you so much and I would tape my
lines I said anytime you have Rosa
Starbuck doing this because I was
reading my life but I can't forget it
now it's we've got violent
decompressions of radiating from the
port flight pod now I can't forget it I
have nightmares about port flight pod I
know it's on the left side but III will
never hold it against somebody like to
have met me in that scenario look [ __ ]
it I get it
I met a buddy of mine used to do a
reality show with Gene Simmons called
family Jews it's a whole thing
and so he invited me to go see kiss one
day in Madison Square Garden and like
backstage you're doing a meet and greet
[ __ ] gene it's all on the giant demon
outfit like nine feet tall it was a good
meeting this dude and one guy comes up
and says hey gene I don't know if you
remember but we met four years ago in
Des Moines and gene looks at him like
dead in the eyes and said if you had my
life would you remember you he said oh
my god you killed that poor man
like it's true but you didn't have to
put it that way
but I've always sort of taken it like no
no there's no reason why that person
should have remembered me because I'm
one of a thousand journalists that you
I'm sure you'd met over the course of
the time but here we go you were in my
house later that part you remember I
remember that yeah
I don't know yeah my dad till this day
calls everybody bub came in The Big
Lebowski because he doesn't he didn't
remember anyone's names in high school
so all of our friends were just bub so
now when I meet people my girl What's Up
bub are you doing what's going on Hass
Hass was my favorite are you doing house
that means I don't remember who you are
but here we are and thank you again for
coming to play with me
absolutely are you are you working on
anything we can talk about no I just
finished an episode of the flash which
also long I'm so hoping that I can work
with Kevin and he will direct me someday
on that happen so I got to go and do my
terrible British accent which I love
people either love it or they hate it I
think they're missing the point
it's not real were you were you working
with Damien Poitier I did I love Danny
Portier I just worked with Damien yeah I
mean I got to make out with him shut up
like I crawled up him like a spider
monkey I mean like I I don't like to go
out with him like in the world because
he's like giant and gorgeous and he's
got these eyes and these guys are like
yellow enemies he's a black dude with
crazy [ __ ] like light hazel eyes yeah
like Damon you're not fair he's like
six-car he's sick so like big yeah and
like [ __ ] martial arts dude he's he's
Luke Cage
he was the stunt double for mike colter
on Luke Cage he's that [ __ ] guy yeah
so I start I steer clear like a teddy
bear to his lovely and
yeah and he let me take advantage of him
in character but we can't be in the same
room together because my self-image will
not stand just like I'm going home man I
lost everything
[Laughter]
yeah like I think a Giselle band I share
the same birth month literally we are
the same age and I'm like this that no
not at all not I don't know how that
happened
he's the best version of 47 I am NOT
whatever Robin Wright Penn and I have
the same birthday and she's older than
me and I keep hoping that that's what
I'm gonna like look like I mean I think
you're you and that is a happy to skip I
am a big [ __ ] jump before I get to
like yeah man sure I could be Luther
Luther Vandross maybe did you see idris
post a picture of him when he was like
in 1995 and he still looked like Rico
suave like he stole every night you'd
gloat out of the wounds I look at me I'm
still string her down always stringer
bell and then someone else posted a
picture who was it that it was well John
posted one Chrissy Teigen
yeah so he posted one he literally
looked like Steve Urkel yeah that dude
bad - dude who had some work done just
soup-to-nuts I don't mean like I got a
boob job but I mean like yeah he put
himself together in a way that it just
did not have to she fixed all that yeah
how was your day it was good
we're working on a Christmas special for
the YouTube channel and so we were at
home all day sort of working on that and
getting it together and sort of dealing
with the sponsor and trying to figure
out what's funny and since we don't have
snow in Los Angeles so it's like whoa we
could go snowshoeing
Christmas to the beach yeah Sandman yes
all that stuff so that's what I did
today I think I think that's what I did
today I mean it's all good I feel like I
didn't mean I might have been more [ __ ]
I have showered hey you know what thank
you so much you really thank you
oh and we watched Revenge of the Sith we
were watching that awesome cool yeah all
right I
I watched the men head you have feelings
about the Mandalorian I have positive
feelings about the Mandalorian and I
have seen your sweet yes the first time
I saw it it softened somewhat I just
gave up yes I
we watched the the pilot episode in the
writers room where I'm currently working
on a show that I cannot talk about
because you know whatever so we're gonna
stand up here and talk about all the
shows we can't talk yeah she's gonna be
like NDA City like what are you doing
can't say no Ali yes the green room man
what are you working on can't talk about
it but you working on can talk about it
yes fuckin'-a so yeah and so you're kind
of watched it and we've been you know as
you do laboring to build a season long
pitch for this show we're working on
well we're hammering out all the beats
and all the character stuff and and like
we got to make sure we're gonna action
in here or the female characters popping
all this stuff doing now you watch the
pilot of the mandalorian it's like well
what's happening here not much like he
gets he goes into a bar beats up a
couple dudes it goes into a ship is a
nice thing that he deals with pretty
quickly then kind of goes to another
place talks about currency for a stretch
like we don't take these currencies we
take those currencies what about those
don't do that anymore
but he's called weather so that's cool
and then he goes and talks to like a
like a like a German documentarian who
seems to work for the Empire man is like
I've got another job for you but we
don't pay any real money it's like more
my [ __ ] okay let's talk about the
financial systems of the post Empire
there's a brain home that Mandalorians
like work for money
I totally do he's making sure you got
that I only take the calamari pogs
sure we do you remember what the money
looks like
yeah little poker chippy things yeah but
it's like slimy right uh-huh okay well
you remember it so it obviously made an
impression I mean it did its thing it
did its thing right and so like the
German documentary and it's like alright
go and do this thing I'm gonna pay you
in this little slab of metal which means
something to you because Mandalorians
and then he goes and like welds a thing
for a while and has flashbacks and then
you have two characters who don't have
heads talking to each other and like I
don't know what people feel about this
exchange because they don't have faces
and I can't see eyes whatever okay and
then he's like I'm going to this place
and he lands and it's like how am I
gonna get to that place I got to ride
this ball sack here because we we wanted
like a Bronco busting part of this show
because we're only 38 minutes long and
we can't spare weren't you amazed that
the like the agility of them I was like
wow they move real good for like chubby
things my pug moved that fast
oh [ __ ] she deserves our show too would
you look at them and and so then they
ride the ball sacks to a place that he
couldn't fly a spaceship to for reasons
and then lands south man's doubts all
about so it's all about self Lauria the
decision your dentistry smoking diet oh
thanks Nick Nolte and then so they its
latest Nick Nolte's voice like he's that
dude because Nick Nolte and after then
they get to the little like Old West
town where take it again because we love
the tanker so Tigers IG 11 yes I'm going
to activate my self-destruct mechanism
know and like that's fun city hops on
the [ __ ] like blaster cannons spins
around it's like disco fever and he
blows up all the bad dudes and then
finds baby Yoda and I'm like okay I mean
sure well weren't you shocked by that
cuz you're like do baby Yoda's 50 yea
he's 50 years old since the German
documentarian you have to be Garrard gym
which is yeah cool and it's like baby
Yoda
knew it was in Jena because she's not
fifty so I was like who is it that
they're trying to find yeah and it's
baby it's baby Yoda baby [ __ ] Yoda
which is the most adorable version of
Yoda I think I've ever seen he's sort of
like the Puss in Boots cat with the eyes
make the big eyes
know what you need me to do I don't need
the force I got these eyes I'll make you
do whatever just look at me just look at
me so I was I was underwhelmed the first
time I saw it and then I saw it again
and I watched one and two together kind
of back-to-back twice and by the time I
watched the second time I'm like okay
and I realized something but I always
tend to forget which is Star Wars is and
always has been for children and it is
not like it's not like Harry Potter
Harry Potter grows with the audience
like Harry Potter begins as a [ __ ]
scooby-doo mystery and becomes this
[ __ ] nihilistic super goth version of
all of my friends are gonna die
everything I love is gone and like hope
is a tiny flicker that I'm gonna try and
fan otherwise Baltimore it's gonna kill
everything and everyone this is like
kind of always for kids and when I
forget that it's when I become
disappointed by it and that's totally
fun because I saw it when I was a kid
and I loved it when I was a kid and it
did all of the things for me as a kid
but I've grown up and expect things from
something that it's not giving me
anymore and if that's my fault like
that's not the contents fault and I love
it that is for kids and I love it and
kids would totally get off on we're
gonna ride this ball sack for a while
and fall off a little bit then hop back
on it and he learned a thing he learned
how to ride something today and that's
totally cool and once I kind of turned
that corner I accepted it for what it
was not what I wanted it to be and I
think that that's it's it's always
instructive for me to greet art on its
own terms like not to bring myself into
it too much but to let it be what it is
and the version that that is is pretty
fun like it's not about taxation tariffs
and trade blockades and all that [ __ ]
which is the mistake George Lucas made
which was i'ma try and grow this [ __ ]
now George we don't want that I loved it
I loved it
I also barely graduated from high school
so maybe I'm a child no I I loved it you
know I've been fan of it we've talked
about this a little bit outside that I
have been a fan of Star Wars since I was
a kid and and so for me I love the world
I love what what all the movies I've
done I love what Clone Wars and rebels
have done where they've they've slotted
themselves in so you can now go back and
watch it in different order and
appreciate it for different reasons it's
like a choose your own adventure story
which I love I'm like oh let's go this
way and then we checked like I love it I
loved every second of it and I yeah I
just can't wait to see what they keep
doing but that I am in you know he does
pay my salary [ __ ] yes get that money
and I I do appreciate it and respect it
for doing the thing that I've always
wanted Star Wars to start doing I've
never been a sort of expanded universe
person I've been very mainline I've been
a very bunch about the movies about
Clone Wars and ever got that deep into
rebels but like I love that they're
finding new stories to tell in this
world because for too long it's felt
like we're all about the [ __ ]
Skywalker's and I get it but we're
coming to the end of that so what's the
rest of this world like I love about it
it's such a vast world and there are so
many interesting places to go and I
honestly feel like if done well over at
Disney plus they have the ability to
twist and turn this into so many
different like iterations of it and as a
fan of sci-fi for me like that's just it
could be different like multiple
different shows it could mean more
movies it could be so many different
things and I love the idea that it could
just continue to grow for me I think
that's cool yeah I want I want new
places and new planets I want things
that I've never seen before and I'm
hoping the mandalorian goes there
because for now is it's a little
familiar even just texturally like Jawas
and say
and like I get it like I spent a lot of
these movies here what else we got like
bring me someplace new do the new things
and that excites me about the potential
of Star Wars and if this is the first
step into a brave new world totally down
I mean they have enough money so they
are never gonna go hungry know where the
Disney please we watched the Jeff
Goldblum thing on Disney Plus how was
that he's a minute chef kobliner it's
crazy like good crazy or like crazy I
feel like I went in with an expectation
and like I feel like I should have
watched it as a child not an adult for
children yes as a person who has worked
at a couple of different streamers over
time how do you feel the I guess we're
calling them streaming Wars is going to
shake out like they're there will come a
time where we are going to have to pay
as much for the various streamers that
we now pay for cable if you still have
cable well it's completely cyclical
we're gonna end up in the exact same
place where we were 15 years ago we're
gonna bundle everything up people are
gonna start buying each other amazon's
gonna own netflix soon and we're all
just gonna like bundle it up and then
we'll pay for those bundles again and
it's just it's gonna continue to go like
this it's just this has happened before
and it'll happen again
uh-huh I didn't even tee you up for that
those nice [ __ ] got there it's like
you've done this before you'll do it
again yeah should we talk about some
news sure let's talk about news let's
talk about the news here's the part of
the show where Kevin usually says that I
scour the Internet's looking for news
and then I copy paste them and put them
into a document then read them out loud
but I said it now because Kevin's not
here so [ __ ] that dude I know I have
been in like construction hell in my
house for like three months so like it
depends on what kind of news you're
talking about cuz this may I mean are we
gonna talk about impeachment hearings
I can't no bottle of whiskey please
I don't drink during the week but I'm
making an exception because I stopped
drinking during the week because as I
get older I was like wow like it's not
as easy to stay in shape as it used to
be and I don't want to go on a diet so
I'll just stop drinking during the week
it's like you should write a book it
works like this shortest book ever just
don't drink it's every Sunday drink
whatever you want it's all [ __ ] good
if you can rock this great so late
breaking news are you a Star Trek fan
along with your Star Wars miss did you
never swing that way oh I swung that way
for about four years and then I figured
out that that wasn't me underhand they
are they're going to make another Star
Trek movie the writer director of said
Star Trek movie will be Noah Holly are
you familiar with the know Holly's no no
Holly is the writer creators actor
producer of Legion and Fargo on the FX
and so JJ I don't think we'll have very
much to do with this version of Star
Trek they are now time of doing the kind
of thing that I'm applauding DC for
doing at this point which is let's give
it to somebody else like let's give it
to this guy who has vision
like let's make the weird anthology
version of Star Trek where we just get a
bunch of talented people to come in and
give us their take yeah on the final
frontier absolutely and we I mean
honestly like it would have been really
cool to see a Quentin Tarantino version
of Star Trek but we all knew that was
never gonna happen I mean that's not
dead they're calling it a spin-off and
sure I mean I'd love to see it I'd love
to see the hateful eight [ __ ] you [ __ ]
you cooking devices are B me up [ __ ]
face you beam up it's Salma Hayek with a
snake wrapped around her I had this
phaser buried in my ass for four years
and I brought it back for you so we
Belle jumped out gotta want that I kind
of want that too let's get rid of the
old starch I can do that [ __ ] you guys
everybody's ass this got really weird
Quinn I know and nobody wears shoes on
the enterprise
Jesus scribbles like remember the little
zit tribbles ladies just a bunch of
tribbles just wait you realize this
they've just come like a bunch of cokes
those are drugs and devices including
adorable aren't they yeah dilithium we
just snort it just whaling it off or
something no I'm just saying we we got
spun this behind a bar the other day
we're not drinking not during the week
we should shoot I'm at my best here's
what's happening guys off the final
frontier you know the final frontier is
everything's ass
that reminds me of an episode of Rick
and Morty when is it gerbils no it's not
gerbils that was Richard Gere it fits
the Hedgehog's people's asses when they
live in people's asses did you guys
watch that Rick and marnya okay I just
for a second I thought I was on my own
there just lick yourself clean the whole
thing and the whole time traveling and
that's amazing I think we should call
paramount week well you might have an
agent I fired mine yeah because I'm a
writer and we had to do that oh you all
had to do that we all had to do that so
yeah you call your agent and be like I
gotta take a voyage to Uranus I like it
wordplay
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[ __ ] it like fan video I'm not busy okay
on our weekends shoot everything
are you a Lord of the Rings fan you are
just mentioned everything that my eye
we're skipping the ball yeah um I um I
am a lord the Rings fan are you looking
forward to the new show that Amazon is
currently making yeah I mean I think
that anytime you take that world and
throw so much money out its gonna look
visually amazing yes they will have
spared no expense
right to re-render middle-earth again
there's a first season that is currently
in production and they already greenlit
season 2 oh yeah we haven't and we won't
see season 1 for like another year but
they're making more because you're doing
things now and when you spend 250
million dollars for the rights to then
make it show that's gonna cost you
another hundred million dollars you kind
of have to you're making five seasons of
that
you have to yeah you have the money back
yeah they're doing the same thing with
The Witcher which waiter The Witcher is
a Henry Cavill is playing a half which
half blonde naked dude I think from what
I gather by the trailer scene everyone's
gonna close yeah
so it's a lot of like these are there's
like platinum blonde hair and his own
okay I know it's really stimulating they
spared no expense
yeah come on that's that's our budget
it's just working you out of he was the
budget yeah we got him
what's your gonna do I don't know be
shedders doing it it doesn't matter but
it's based on a series of novels that
have then been turned into a video game
that was insanely popular I think he
hunt witches or is a witch who hunts
other witches beg to the Witcher
The Witcher I mean it's witches involved
unless he's just an indecisive person
which should I do
which way do I go
which of these shirts should I not wear
today the blue one or the other one
neither
I'm just trying clothes on for women
okay men honestly n you can fix this
tomorrow we good I feel like we're
creating so much good [ __ ] content
right now I mean I am I am I'm ride or
die for the great british baking show oh
my god me too I'm oh it's the best show
on TV if you've been watching I'm pretty
sure if evangelized about this before
but if you've ever like had a slightest
bit of a bad day put that on everything
goes away everything goes away you're
just like oh they're all gonna be very
nice to each other and they go to bacon
how do you need sugar I've got more
sugar for you do you need help with you
think about bread and they're like it's
not lysing it's yours rising mines
uprising
what do we do i what did you put in your
[Music]
theme is it oh you word dates in yours
oh that's so brilliant I like oh I
really want a toughy pudding and if you
[ __ ] up my toffee pudding I'm gonna be
very put out Christmas ones are good
it's amazing but it's basically just
watch people bake for like eight weeks
and if they put henry cavill in it make
it it would be so much better no just
watching that dude just like all right
what you guys put in yours yeah I don't
know what you put in yours I don't know
I'm making a kryptonite gig I'm not sure
I sprinkled some numberless [ __ ] on it
so I good I don't know if that's his
voice hey I worked on the show which I
can't talk about called carnival row is
that your jam precisely your jam it was
a ton of fun but meeting Orlando Bloom
was lovely but his his tough-guy voice
in the show was my favorite thing
Biggers he did he played he'd like
talked like a heavy the whole times
there's something going on in the burgh
I'm like dude I know who you are you're
not that guy
some dolt God wakes no no not so much
Legolas you carry a lighter buddy I
loved it cuz I got paid for it I loved
it to think you should love it too I do
but that voice killed me I must be a
real easy sell cuz I method I just
imagine that that's Henry's cavils
trying on clothes voice should I do the
Oxford collar which way do I go oh sure
cyan or magenta I could do either one
cuz look at my body but my eyes the blue
picks up a siren better alright let's go
that's the whole [ __ ] show that's the
whole shouts do it and in a low moment
he drops the shirt this way yeah oh did
you did you see something that what
happened
British baking show first time we travel
Henry Cavill neither as a stone this is
usually what happens kevin is here isn't
these weird-ass conversation called the
sacks and he pivots like how do we get
here I don't know how we got here and my
job is to be like the ways to lead us
back to the conversation where it's no
worry the straight guy I'm the [ __ ]
[ __ ] go with me my job is to be like
there we went this way boss and that's
how we found it I'm glad it's written
down because I'm like a deer in
headlights know how we got a pretty face
Henry Cavill and then Henry Cavill
trying on clothes would be the most
amazing thing even there's no plot did
you ever watch the weirdest baking show
no plot an adorable British people just
doing cool [ __ ] Thank You Henry Cavill
got it in one full circle Colonel
Mustard in the observatory with a pipe
full of weed okay so a thing that one of
your ex-boyfriends had nothing to do
with so far did you ever read the Elric
books Elric of Melanie bunny no on the
bone they are not quite like Tolkien
level popular but they're kind of on par
with Conan the Barbarian a little bit
higher than like John Carter of Mars but
it was this sort of high fantasy series
about myself who never fit in with his
people and like when I'm doing elf [ __ ]
likes pretty great yeah and there's like
nine novels of them and and you lost me
mass yeah how many no I did that was
baby-sitters club they are making a TV
series of this too because now nothing
nothing gets done nothing yeah the the
interesting part about it is that Glen
Mazzara is there gonna be the showrunner
upset thing okay Glen Mazzara who did
the shield and you did Walking Dead for
a stretch you did Damien a lovely
gentleman and a super smart [ __ ]
writer so I'm I will write or die for
that dude and what he does that sounds
awesome
I actually kind of want to read the
books now looking for set of books to
read
speaking of books that you may or may
not have read
I'm really good at the segways that's
that's my secrets almost as if I knew
you were going there were you a Sin City
fan of the comic books Frank Miller I
didn't I mean I have seen the comic
books um but I was not like a die-hard
fan now did you see the movie I did did
you like the movie
I did there was gonna be a TV show that
is awesome from Frank Miller and Robert
Rodriguez Frank Miller is amazing and
Robert Rodriguez is amazing so yeah no
Frank Miller Frank Miller defined to a
certain degree my young comic book
fandom between his daredevil Ron and
then [ __ ] Dark Knight Returns and
then Sin City and then Ronin and 300
like all of those works sort of the the
late 80s mid to late 80s all the way up
to the to the early 2000s I should have
brought my boyfriend cuz he's like
really you guys could sit here and talk
about comic books forever cuz he's such
a cute nerd I don't know why you didn't
should have brought it he makes me look
smarter oh yeah well tell him the
mechanics in City Show
he'll be excited I always wanted it to
be an animated show though because the
the look of those comic books were so
striking was all black and white it was
all super just these bold swaths of just
blacks and deep pink sand and just white
highlights for stuff that it always felt
and the movie gets as close as it's
gonna get cuz I was gonna say the movie
is so similar to that that yeah yeah but
I was gonna want to just a full-on 2d
animated version of that to be as close
as possible and I think they're gonna do
they're planning a live-action show much
in that style but also spin off like
animated shorts also out of that world
where is it where is it living legendary
has it now legendary the same people who
did Pacific Rim carnival row the dune
show dune it was one of my favorites
hands up dune
[Music]
me too it's it's like every now and
again you find a person who's like yeah
fears of mind killer right yeah my dad
raised me on sci-fi and dune was one of
his favorites that's the one yeah yeah
yeah
the book was always like lanes I'm
wearing the house I I saw the movie
first okay and and it was the first
movie that ever challenged me in a real
way because it's batshit crazy and makes
very little sense yeah but I kept on
thinking am I'm not working hard enough
to understand this like let's watch it
again because it's so weird and kind of
awesome but it's a superhero story it's
about this kid who like thanks to the
you know genes and drugs discovers that
you know what I am I'm the quiz that's
[ __ ] had a rack man I'm the sleeper
who's about to awaken now I can control
all this [ __ ] and what the movies weird
and like doesn't connect a lot of dots
yeah then maybe it's a little strange
yeah have you ever seen the the Alan
Smithee cut over the movie no Alan
Smithee in case you guys don't know is
the pseudonym that directors take when
they want to remove their names from the
movie when like it's been butchered
beyond their recognition and like you
know what I don't want credit for this
Alan Smithee is gonna be the director
really and so the Alan Smithee cut is a
four and a half hour cut of that movie
with everything they shot everything
like everything like everything like
stuff that doesn't make sense like this
drawings on the screen there's just like
everything that could have possibly been
put into that movie they put back and
you watched it like four times
really it still doesn't make that much
sense but that was my next question
I mean it's like some of the [ __ ] that
you like gets like e'er some of the [ __ ]
this is some of the stuff like it kind
of just it starts to try and like
pretending to thread more [ __ ] together
but it doesn't quite it's just like more
Daffy batshit like and if you like Daffy
batshit four and a half hours of that
Daffy bad [ __ ] four and a half hours
yeah like every now and again sci fi
well like they do it over holidays we're
like at two o'clock in the morning doing
the Alan Smithee cottage is all of it
like 2 a.m. to 7 a.m. if I just some
weird [ __ ]
remember when they used to make movies
that's like it's a hallmark version of a
sci-fi film like the abominable Ant Man
he's nobody's ant like Oh like one dude
thought up a pun they like shoot it
doesn't matter just go just do it
we have no money and a guy in an ant
suits we can get John Larroquette for
three days I'll be your archaeologist
finding the abominable snow lady person
so many of those good ones I just I have
like weird ask PTSD flashbacks of like
man skeet oh yes and lava Langella yeah
I like that
do you remember Louisville Angela oh I
don't remember Louisville and it's great
it's I'm not sure if you can figure out
where we're going but like it's in LA
cuz of course and even though they're
shot in Vancouver but like there's a
thirst there's a valet didn't look
remarkably like thank you so there's a
volcano that's about to show up in LA
okay in the Hollywood Hills but instead
of just lava like tarantulas made of
lava come crawling out of the cracks
it's almost like spiders fire spiders
looks like Hayden Christensen crawling
out of the butt and it's like I think
like Lou Diamond Phillips is in it like
trying to save a kid I love Lou he's
great but it's like that's the dude who
got paid that week they paid real good I
mean that's like that Union money it's
yeah you got a couple ex-wives Oh sci-fi
middle of night crazy [ __ ] dude
legendary Sin City yes that that is a
lot of control-z right there I'm just
like undoing I'm doing undoing oh that's
where we started I would never have been
able to figure that out I know that
rosario Dawson was in my head though
she's in Sin City
that's why and I would have gotten back
to since I mean
she's always in my head so like that's
not that big a clue for me so you're
Henry Cavill I mean yeah like what's
Rosario gonna try on today
we'll watch that Cavill like have tea at
the beginning of every episode and then
she's shopping
you should have them in an episode of
British Bake Off just the two of them a
Christmas edition your Netflix check
that's our third one of the night if
anyone is it we just start a company
where's the dear Netflix behind the bar
productions what do we think of today
behind the bar you know would be great
so good dream about this tonight now all
right good luck
um were you well let me see where your
fan I'm not your fan that's not the
question but it's arrow has wrapped
production arrow has wrapped production
it is the the beginning of the end of an
era which is arrow was the the font from
which the rest of the Berlanti were
sprung yeah it was always the kind of
spine of all those shows everything kind
of connected back to arrow whenever they
would do the crossovers they all kind of
funneled back into the air over sand
well it's Oliver Queen gonna do this
year what's he gonna lose last year they
did nine right eight eight eight seasons
which will culminate at least four arrow
in the crisis on Infinite Earths stuff
yes what is it like I have never done
this but you have been on shows that
have wrapped production what's the what
how do you feel unlike that last day
when it's series wrap on Katee Sackhoff
i have to say when it was Battlestar I
was ready for it to be over you know it
was a long series we did 22 episodes a
season it was exhausting playing a
character that was so angsty and
miserable all the time and so it was
really hard to play her so when that was
over I was just I just wanted to break
like had they said hey we're gonna take
a year off and come back it would have
been like perfect but you know in lieu
that the show ended basically so and
then when Longmire was over I actually
you know it was really sad because I
highly enjoyed the pace of the show we
only did ten episodes a season it was
really like an easy run for us and I
loved them like family very similar to
battles they're people so I cried my
eyes out for like a good week when that
one ended but you know it's um I'm sure
that Stevens ready to to be done you
know they've done I can't speak from
obviously but they've done 22 episodes
is hard when you're the lead I mean you
know I just did the the lead for ten
episodes and it I was exhausted I can't
imagine doing that for 22 seasons eight
years I don't think I want to I don't
know I don't think I would all right
yeah yeah I've never quite had that
experience I mean I've had jobs because
you know I have clothes at some point
like their shitty clothes unless you're
like your parents send you stuff so yeah
no no no my parents were like you're
done right we did our job we are no
longer legally required to do anything
for you I think my brother still gets
care packages for my mom like frozen
enchiladas and socks so yeah I don't I
mean I've left jobs which the jobs that
have been out for a long time some under
great conditions some under less so but
I just I've never quite been you know
the the TV camp that it is of making a
TV show and for that to come to an end
for something to have defined your life
for as long as it did you know I'm sure
Stephen has done things before arrow
will do things after arrow but like this
was the thing like in some actors you
know as talented as they may be we'll
only get the one thing not saying that
that's his fate but this is like James
Gandolfini was like I Sopranos is my TV
show it's the one I'm probably going to
do
I'm not gonna do another one of these as
far as I can tell so like a I get paid
while I can what I can and take it but
also like when it's over it's it's a
legit like you're ending a chapter in
your life yeah I try to you know all
these all these call them kids they're
only like 10 years younger than me but
like all of these these people that are
younger than me that are on a series
that are maybe not as happy as they you
know should be I try to remind them that
like that yeah there's no guarantee
you're gonna get another one of these
like you know if to go from series to
series to series is a very rare thing
and if you have the bird in the hand and
it's got an audience and and you can
find some way to make yourself enjoy
that craft daily stay because you are so
lucky to be where you're at and and I
think that i think that performers
sometimes lose sight of the fact that
this is a job and if you're not acting
you're not an actor so yeah so I don't
know I you know you look at Jensen and
Jared and you know the leaving
supernatural very similar 11 years or
whatever and and Jared's already off
doing you know Walker Texas Ranger with
a abominable ant man you know but he's
you know back in Texas which is where
he's from so like there's a reason for
him to do that and like it's you know
you gotta set yourself up for the long
haul yeah I think that's it's actors act
like people people last me on line all
the time say man I want to be a writer
like what do I need to do like right
right it's literally right there in the
title like writers right I get it to a
certain degree you can write for money
and hopefully you get there and you
could write for passion you could write
because it's your only way out whatever
it is you had a right mm-hmm and through
the writing and you're better at it and
if you're better at it and that will be
get success but you know it is a career
in the arts is about doing the art and
it's like and it's the only way out oh
yeah no it's it's you've you've got to
work and you've got to you know
practice your craft craft and stretch
your muscles constantly or you're not
you're not growing so for sure what is
your relationship harsh left to Eddie
Murphy are you an any Murphy fan I mean
yes I'm an American
oh yeah absolutely I love any Murphy
did you watch dolomite my name is
dolomite don't know it is uh it okay
what is it dolomite first dolomite was a
series of movies made by a failed
comedian failed musician successful
blaxploitation dude named Rudy ray Moore
who had no other talent than being like
a bit of a hustler and a bit of a
shyster and like made his own like I
want to be in movies you're fat and ugly
I'm gonna put you in movies we don't be
a singer you can't sing I want to be
sterile community not that funny but he
found a way he built this personality
called dolomite which is like this is
weird as urban preacher slash superhero
slash kung fu legend and then stitched
together enough money to make the first
dolomite movie called dolomite is my
name and it was one of the first indie
film successes like they made it during
the blaxploitation period when that
audience shorted for anything they
released it privately and like in one
fear in the middle of nowhere and it
sold out and so the Eddie Murphy movie
called old man is my name is like the
bow finger of that movie it's like the
Ed Wood of that movie that here's how a
bunch of like hardscrabble dudes who
have no reason to be able to do this did
this and so it's this kind of like
heartwarming feel-good comedy about
artists trying to make art and all the
obstacles that come to that like we
don't have enough power in this building
to actually flood the lights great tap
into the streetlights outside we don't
have enough for this great
oh you're fat Natalie what make it a
comedy but it's it's the how you solve
problems with nothing to make something
that people respond to okay that sounds
awesome um it's pretty great it's like
in 90 minutes long and it was written by
by Miss remember the names but the dudes
wrote Ed Wood Larry karaszewski and Ed's
something or other [ __ ] that makes me
feel bad but no that's the script is
great Eddie is having the time of his
and he did it for Netflix because like
this day and age movie studios are not
funding movies that like it's for adults
it's gonna cost 30 million dollars I put
it in theaters they didn't mean it for
Netflix and it did very well for them
so the point where now he's going to
Netflix to do Beverly Hills Cop for that
makes me really yeah like I know that
three is hot garbage we have a very
different opinion yourself cough no I
think that movies are supposed to
entertain and take you out of your life
for 90 minutes and if you were if you
were entertained for 90 minutes and
forgot about the [ __ ] that's going on in
your own life just for a second it's a
good movie that's that's that it's a
defendable position so I think I just
have very I go in with zero expectations
I do watch homework like Christmas movie
marathons too so you know I try to treat
every movie on its own terms but Beverly
Hills Cop one is maybe the best movie of
the 80s I concur
you know it's phenomenal it does all the
things that it does so well one of the
reasons is because it was never supposed
to be a comedy like it was going to be a
Sylvester Stallone cop drama and then
slaw dropped out and Eddie signed on and
the like oh it's [ __ ] Eddie Murphy
mm-hmm none of us who are making this
movie are funny Eddie go be funny and
it's just these moments in the movie
where you just improv sit just like all
right you got to convince these cops not
to follow you banana in the tailpipe
banana in the tailpipe
and we're gonna do four minutes on
banana in the [ __ ] tailpipe and it'll
be great
you know like Eddie we're in a strip
club whatever you say in here is what
you're gonna say because we're not
funnier than you are so have at it like
there's this awesome energy of that
movie that totally makes it work the
second one is like fun because we're
back with [ __ ] Axel Foley and this is
cool he's going to play pro match
that's neat and as Brigitte Nielsen and
that's awesome and the mother third one
it's like wow he's I mean cuz you made
those other ones in like you knew how
that worked and like then you did this
one it is like not that thing and
sometimes they just give a lot of money
they do but I am I am looking forward
I'm loving this phase that all of my
childhood heroes are in which is I'm
gonna do the thing that I did before one
last time you know like just alone I'm
gonna make one more [ __ ] Rocky movie
Creed and then commit to whatever he
won't go away he will go away
he's God do one more another [ __ ]
Rambo and then you know Tom Cruise I'm
gonna do another [ __ ] Top Gun one more
Terminator like a mother and she's like
[ __ ] you all I get back in shape I'm
gonna come and kill it right like I just
love this like all the things that I
loved as a child they're not coming back
to me and all the actors that I loved as
a child are now like one more time one
more and I I'm a sucker for the one last
heist story and this is all this is like
one last heist for your love buddy what
would be your one last that they haven't
made that you want them to make I I
desperately desperately want them to
make old Conan the Barbarian
I mean I want I want Arnold to come
Arnie yeah like again be like he's that
[ __ ] king of Aquilonia like the books
always said he's got a family and the
family is like his son gets kidnapped
and like yeah Conan the Barbarian has to
strap on the [ __ ] sandals and get the
sword out of retirement and like let's
go do some [ __ ] and I get like that's
that would that would just be like with
it right here I just what about you do
you have one naked gun
well or J's looking for money no I you
know I am I mean Charlie she needs a job
we could do another major league yeah
could we could do a major league Mighty
Ducks crossover so like the Estevez boys
are like I love it we're getting paid
you guys shut up and take your check
yeah like Martin Sheen is a commissioner
who's gotta like referee overs like
listen one son we can throw air but in
there just for shits and giggles it's
like your badge the goalie the Disney
animated sports multiverse like we
Michael Jordan throw min yeah we got
this yeah number four if you're keeping
track yes behind the bar productions has
a pitch fee well this is like news news
it's the rock is making a superhero
movie I will always forever call him the
rock I know his name is Dwayne black
lightning Black Adam Black Adam Black
Lightning would be super weird cuz
that's like a straight-up black dude
like for the rock like could we bend
this a little bit I mean it's the rock
you guys
well now it's black Adam who is Captain
Marvel's in the comics I'm going home
okay this had a good time
I killed Kitty psycho in the comics
black Adam was an Egyptian if I remember
correctly who had had the powers of
Captain Marvel like thousands of years
ago and kind of returns to and not like
the lady Captain Marvel like the dude
kept like Shazam with the lightning bolt
and that [ __ ] Carol Danvers who's
awesome I'm sorry I didn't mean to hurt
anybody's feelings
who really loves Billy Batson but and so
in the comics he was a bad guy but
because the rock he's gonna be like I
could inflict a good guy gonna be the
rock [ __ ] Rock and we're gonna smell
what The Rock is cookin
yeah he's like what's through the
eyebrow dude it's like I'm the rock
right I like it I like everything the
rock does I gotta tell you like I said
it's 90 minutes of fun 19 is fun I
remember like very early on when he
started doing it wasn't like for the
Scorpion King but it was like for for
one of his first but he might have been
like the tooth fairy or something a
little girly girl yeah it's super fun so
like he did his very first like big
precedes like it was like you start this
movie you're gonna go and do all the
talk shows you're gonna do you know
Eleanor [ __ ] Rosie O'Donnell at the
time was the pre proto Ellen and and
you're gonna do all the late night shows
and somebody cut together like the clips
of him giving his answers and they were
the same answer to every person it was
like the Machine of it all yeah and it
seemed weird at the time of like onions
just like a robot doing this thing but
then it became clear
oh no you're a robot who's doing this
thing better than anybody else can do it
like he cracked the code just hadn't
polished the code yet yeah
you know like no I'm with my job is to
be incredibly gregarious and totally
charming and sell this movie like nobody
ever sells movies anymore and I will do
every [ __ ] press opportunity I will
fly around the globe I will I will get I
will kiss every baby and shake every
hand until we get this thing to a
billion dollars in the box office and
like that was the beginning of that yeah
all right I gotta learn how to talk to
these people I gotta make it feel
natural I got a I got to be able to sit
on a couch and be awesome for 15 minutes
and then make people come and buy
tickets for my movie yeah I mean I would
there's a I follow him on Instagram I
enjoy the rock I'm convinced when he
goes and works out he motivates me like
in some weird way my god do it arrive
like okay Mina Brody Jake or the cheat
day oh my god his cheat days you guys I
tried to cheat like him yeah I did for
like I'll bet go oh my god oh my god so
like calories literally legit looked at
him and was like The Rock says it's okay
was just like pancakes in the middle of
the night with like peanut butter and
cookies and like sushi on the side like
two shots of tequila happy he looks so
happy
he's private right I want my metabolism
to be that fast but I can eat that much
food and the next morning I like wake up
and I'm still like dehydrated I feel
like you might then have to give up
drinking on weekends too except on
Sundays the Lord the drink on Sunday oh
okay it's the Lord's Day well or it's
this private plane day
where you fly him to the Waffle House
yeah you are there are moments when like
he like will post that like they brought
in his favorite food and like that
favorite food is like 10,000 miles away
and you know that the private plane was
like excuse me we'll be right back we're
gonna go get Benihana Air Force One
doesn't fly like this but we're flying
like this for the rock sure I know it's
good to have dreams the pilot for Air
Force One wishes he works for the rock
right yeah I mean probably in so many
right safer that is all the news we have
today ladies and gentlemen we're closing
a news bag and and now we move to the
part of the show that I like to call Q&A
because that's what it's called
we had we had it we had a news theme
that that malcolm barrett helped out
with when he was here the co-host we
don't have a Q&A theme but if I mean we
could cut and paste that thing and loop
it and Kanye that [ __ ]
peanuts no if you let me know how much
it is cuz I mean you need it for my
youtube channel alright listening to it
all day today trying to find out sweets
expensive okay for our Q&A today we have
a couple of giveaways which is always
nice our good friends at 40 X and screen
X Brett Deacon has given us tickets as
always for screen X which have you ever
been in a screen X theater I don't think
so probably not there's only like a
handful of them in LA but what they do
is it's like you sit in the movies right
it's like a movie screen there and then
like for like 40 minutes out of a movie
suddenly these panels open up on the
side and then the movie becomes this
like 300 degree experience I saw Black
Panther in this form that must have been
in serious [ __ ] nuts
we're in Wakanda and Wakanda every but
are you really fast oh my god Evans junk
is like over your head on your left
thanks junk that's all around you
there's blood lightning is junk is all
around so yes we have three sets of
three D F now 3ds screen next day it's
apparently Ford versus Ferrari in three
in [ __ ] screen x is dope as hell
because it's just like all the racing
[ __ ] is surrounding you so yeah yes
journey as two free tickets to go to
this theater it's amazing and they
played like a dogs journey wow there's a
dog as a Clifford but now it's just
another [ __ ] dog Chris Evans drunken
Salah was drunk that is the smallest
giant dick I've ever seen now would be a
real night down anyway first question
and we also have this giant [ __ ] book
the people at T RA publishing have put
out this book called layer which is all
about supervillain headquarters it's
it's pretty glorious and interviews with
people who've like production designers
and it's mostly bond because Bond movies
about the best but yes they have donated
books for us to give away which is
lovely so yes there's a little prize
pack for you guys well I'm going to have
the best names
they're like stripper names there really
are like my stripper name would be mama
kitty heritage and I also feel like it
works if I was a Bond villain wait what
mama kitty heritage yeah yeah that's a
weird a stripper name yeah coming off
the stage is Tangerang welcome to mama
kitty heritage
she comes she's in vintage clothes oh
yeah she's a flapper hello my darling
hello my ragtime gal I'm never gonna
forget that one behind the bar
Productions presents Mama Kitty heritage
this story of one woman's rise from the
tassel to the castle they're traveling
south alright so sober sober dad coke
you guys it's the cocaine a diet so
who's our first question and ask her so
we can be question-answer remember the
rules both of us have to be able to
answer the question so don't be like
Katie tell me what it was like to be
awesome in behind the [ __ ] cockpit of
a Viper because I don't know what that's
like
yeah you can't ask us what day it is I
hope my questions okay mark and Katie
what Susan Susan oh nice to meet you
what you got pardon look at my beautiful
um so what's the deal on this new
Battlestar Galactica series do you guys
know anything about it
can you talk is this one of your secret
things you can't talk about no they
can't afford me I hear well so alright
[ __ ] it you go first you go first baby I
I had alluded to it on a past episode
and I had JC cut out all mentions of it
but not [ __ ] it because what are they
gonna do keep not paying me sure I think
it fired twice nothing
you're fired no no no I just wasn't hot
yeah you didn't get the job right so
they can't be like hey buddy hey hey
still didn't get it did you imagine you
have the job now you're fired yeah I did
what psych click I I was invited to
pitch an idea for the new Battlestar
Galactica TV show right well no no
probably because and before I even did
that I went to Tricia my co-host on the
Battlestar Galactica and then I went to
Ron Moore I went to David I went to all
of them and I'm like hey so they've
asked me if I want to try and pitch on
this do I have your blessing and they
all said sure just don't do any of this
[ __ ] that we did meaning like like and
Ron was very sort of sanguine about it
he said I rebooted a thing like it's not
mine I didn't invent this the things
that I did invent I want to keep like so
I don't want a president Rosalind to
show up I don't want a chief Terrell to
show up I don't want to doc Cottle to
show up but you can have your ball tars
you're gonna have your indominus you can
have your Apollo's and your Starbucks
like anything that was in the seventies
show you can have anything that was in
my show get the [ __ ] out of Dodge
and I said I respect that I get it
totally cool
Sam s mail the guy was producing it also
understood that that's the agreement
that they had and so Ron was super cool
about it it's like you know Madison
you're not like kissing my wife because
I was kissing another dudes wife and
that's all fine so but I didn't want to
do the same show like because I was
never gonna be better at it than Ron was
like that
Battlestar is my favorite show of the
last like 25 years it is it is a signal
work of television it is phenomenal it
does all the things that it does
incredibly well even and we've gotten
two episodes Trish and I and doing the
battle side lactic acid where they're
episodes that like don't quite land as
well as I would hope they would land
it's not because they weren't trying
hard it's because the the reach exceeded
their grasp as opposed to we just made a
shitty episode of TV you know like oh no
there's a shitty episode of Magnum
yeah sure because it just is like this
was a show that was always like swinging
for the fences and sometimes you just
didn't connect right so I didn't want to
do anything about I didn't want to touch
any of that so I came up with a take
that was like a radically different so
radical that it was too different but
and and ultimately they said well we
want to go that way and we know
immediately like the take was like so
[ __ ] like oh no there's no humanoid
Cylons oh no you know there's nobody's
traveling from planet to planet there's
one planet and that planet is called
Galactica okay cool not so cool for them
which is fine like the the job of being
a screenwriter in Hollywood pitching on
open projects is sometimes you get it
most times you don't and this was a term
that I didn't and so I spent three weeks
like playing in this world that I love
to death didn't happen totally cool
I think they will crack it in some
fashion I think we will see a Battlestar
reboot that may or may not play in the
same universe as Ron show which place in
the same universe is that Glenn Larson
show but it won't be mine I will I will
maybe subscribe to peacock Bradley for
the [ __ ] punky Brewster's show and I
didn't want to have frakking it I was
like that's too tight now I can't walk
in those footsteps do you have feelings
yeah I mean I really don't care um the
best attitude I I do in the sense that
like if they were to redo what we did
and hire a blonde chick that looked just
like me and was 22 I'd be like wow that
was really shitty but if they do
something in the world you know I think
that the world is big enough to have
there's 41,000 characters left on this
show to choose from it's literally
written on a chalkboard you can you can
follow new people the the problem that I
feel like they're gonna run into is that
they did that with blood and chrome and
Caprica and it didn't work as well as
Battlestar Galactica so they've already
tried that so I worry that they're gonna
just go back and do what they say
they're not gonna do and
you remake it again that would be my
only fear but listen I mean go for it
have fun you know I think that I think
there's some really heavy big shoes to
fill and God bless him yeah like my my
take on it was always somebody's gonna
make this show is Patricia Tobin she's
like somebody's gonna do it might as
well be like somebody's gonna make it
like and it'll be what it is definitely
it's its own thing
I'd love for it to be its own thing
because I want more new things like we
live in this weird-ass world where
everything is kind of reheated and
rebooted and reefs equal than we
imagined like be your own thing be
something new that's the thing we are
we're at a shortage of is the new I
would really love for them to you know
continue to find new science fiction
shows that that haven't been made before
and and get behind those and give money
to those and and you know there are so
many amazing writers that have new and
fresh ideas and I would love to see a
show that's better than Battlestar
Gallactica get made you know I'd like to
see them try but yes thank you did that
answer for you awesome come and take
things don't run away yet don't you get
to go see a dogs journey
you get to see dogs journey who else we
got who's got a question that needs
answering I can't fix your car hey man
how's it going tell me your name again
Mike hey Mike how's it going so I'm
doing well so my question is who in your
life do you look up to that's not a real
person
so what non-fictional character do you
take those character yes sorry sorry
yeah
don't choose a non-fiction choose a
fiction that you look up to for their
ideas their ability to solve problems
you know who who in your life do you go
all
gambits I really like how he's just so
suave and I want to be more suave like
gambit that's not who I would choose I
just trying to pick someone but do you
have one a fictional hero or heroine
that inspires you on to greatness Jesus
Christ
wait is that your answer there I mean I
you know I don't know I mean I always
grew up idolizing Sigourney Weaver and
so I'm just for lack of a better
answered like that to me
she sort of heard curtain I mean it was
a real person but Ripley
so I loved Ripley and she sort of when I
got the opportunity to place stronger
characters I loved the vulnerability and
the femininity that she brought to a
strong masculine role and so that's
always been sort of I loved her I don't
know if that's exactly what your
question was no no I think that works so
you found someone that you could relate
to something that you pull from to try
and emulate in your life to better
yourself correct good answer well done
I said Nancy Drew honestly and it's not
because no [ __ ] it it's it's William
Adama it is it is as a person who has
found himself in management positions
looking to the way bill Adama on
Battlestar Galactica
deals with people who work for him work
with him how he deals with crisis how he
deals with new information like he's
he's a man who does not seem to be
afraid of admitting that he's wrong he's
not a man who seems to be afraid to
recalibrate based on the presence of new
information he there's this there's this
great line when
when I think it's buckets Gaeta comes to
him it's it's when they're stealing the
election right and Gaeta discovers that
like there's something wrong with these
ballots I don't know how to say this and
he says fast them straight is what I'd
advise like that that feeling that just
be direct like say what you mean mean
what you say like if you give your word
you keep it you do the right thing by
the people that you love you you protect
the people that you care for and you you
are willing to put it all on the line
for the cause you believe in I think
that that as I began to mature as a
person as a professional as I find
myself in new spheres of my life things
like the management guide by William
Adama this actually comes in handy
because he's that character as presented
and in the couple of times that I've met
edward james olmos seems to also be that
guy which is don't say if you don't mean
it
don't do if you don't believe in it like
find the people you love and protect
them you know and I think that it's it
is as good a path to chart by as any I
found I was gonna ask you actually
because it sounds so much like Edie then
I wonder if the line was in the script
it would not surprise me there was yeah
meaner you know there's there is and
he's a person you want to follow you
know what I mean blankets and it there's
something about it being part of the
military there's something about the
command structure lending that to you
but he's the kind of person who you
would want to be in command and so to
find a way to be the kind of person that
other people would want to follow not
because they have to but because they
get to what that's kind of cool so yes
that would be that's my fictional hero
that's a great answer
I need a mulligan again no it won't work
I'm not quick on my toes you're doing
great though I sold we sold five movies
already retail awesome on your toes
Gilda true could you imagine if I was
like [ __ ] puddin
yes yes she says what's on her mind at
all times you're never to use where you
stand no no she she you know what you're
gonna get you know she she always shows
up for you whether you want or not like
you want a book and you want tickets
thank you very much all right we got one
more question we got one more giant book
which we could use for a home defense or
like propping up tables and [ __ ]
hey man what's your name hey it's Wes
Wes good to meet you Wes we saw you on
the way to the bathroom yeah thanks
sorry about that what you got for us so
I was kind of wondering if there was a
moment in TV or movies or even comics
where you saw a trope coming but then
the plot cat turned on its head that
really surprised you one example that
comes to my mind is the end of Watchmen
with Ozzy Medusa's monologue about it's
gonna happen and everyone telling him oh
we're not gonna let you do that well
it's already in place okay so a trope
coming that subverts the trope yeah my
favorite
[Applause]
do you do you have one no just talk long
alright my favorite order first order
first I'll get there okay all right I'll
start with the salad the calamari
no my favorite version of this is it's a
movie called deep blue sea remember the
sub movie so it's it's this moment which
is like my favorite moment where Samuel
Jackson is playing this this like arctic
explorer dude and so of course they're
like underwater and the [ __ ] shark to
come in is very believable movies yeah
you know and so uh and so like sharks
are coming and they're trapped
underwater and everybody's [ __ ] upset
because they char it's been [ __ ] kill
us and everybody's panicking they're
about to give up and Sam Jackson stands
there in his [ __ ] a wetsuit he's like
we will not give up we will never give
up i watch condom mouth with a bunch of
people and there was the worst version
of it ever and i said we are not gonna
die on this mountain we are not and we
walk down them man we ate a bunch of
people on the way but that's okay like
it's it's a [ __ ] like super rousing
like we are gonna you know we will not
give in we will stand and fight another
night and so he's literally like give
the cameras pushing in really tight and
he's like [ __ ] he's geared up he's
all Sam Jackson you know we're gonna
[ __ ] do it
and then shark bites him in half which
is the most amazing version of that
scene because all the way I feel like oh
he's doing a thing where like
everybody's at the lowest point and your
hero just stands up but he's always like
the magical Negro who's like hey
everybody here's the thing you're
supposed to do when I tell you supposed
to do it [ __ ] Bagger Vance and then like
the white dude goes off and does the
thing and so like they [ __ ] kill him
in the middle of that speech it's so
amazing we're just like did they just
[ __ ] killed Sam Jackson with a shark
like in the middle of his we have to
survive speech yeah
yeah they just did that and the rest of
that movie is suddenly like I will
forgive it everything like it's still
it's dumb as [ __ ] before that it's
dumbest [ __ ] after that but that
moment enshrines it in like cinematic
glory because you just they [ __ ]
killed Sam Jackson with a shark like
Bravo everybody involved
so that's mine I went almost as long as
I could
there's still nothing there's another
I'm trying to think of something I mean
I have I will give you another one the
letter bison to prepare it is for most
of the first half of Iron Man 3 we were
led to believe that Ben Kingsley is
playing the man during right and like
and they announced he was playing the
Mandarin and they were like oh it's
[ __ ] banking as the manor was like
alright well he's like like he's East
Asian kind of howl alright that's cool I
get it I buy it and then you get
spoilers anybody not see Iron Man 3 10
years ago like just want to be clear
also I spoiled deep blue sea before that
so so like halfway through Iron Man 3
they reveal that uh Ben Kingsley is not
playing the Mandarin being a dude an
actor named Nigel who had been like I
had for the role of the Mandarin and
it's phenomenal like that moment because
the marketing told us that he was the
Mandarin the movie was been pressing
down or like he's the [ __ ] manager I
got the ten rings I'm gonna rain hell on
these [ __ ] and then it's like
just like drunk high Ben Kingsley
playing an actor out of his depth who
had had like substance problems and
maybe like a weird sexual harassment
allegation and so it couldn't work in
the UK anymore
it was like we do a fiat analysis what's
happening gasps Mandarin you know this
terrorist now
we go bring me your buddy booze booze
girls girls like it's it's phenomenal
okay so we're looking for we thought
some was gonna happen a movie and then
it didn't right yeah Love Actually oh
here a Knightley I think she's gonna go
with the best friend and she doesn't
nice also right you actually do do you
guys remember that's Christmas movie and
also like he's like played by Andrew
Lincoln right yeah and like super like
pre zombies like you still got hope in
his eyes Andrew Lincoln yeah like young
and handsome he's got it's like a card
game he's like hey I've loved you before
I know this is [ __ ] weird Q to super
Cooper also like crazy stalker II a
little bit and like a do what a thing
that's not cool bro
a little bit like nobody yeah it's like
it's it's the grand romantic gesture
that in most romantic
it's like this say anything moment
totally except she's like mom it didn't
work [ __ ] weird yeah that's the only
one I could think of it's a good one
though I like that thank you
well [ __ ] play thanks well listen my
brain wasn't working very well like a
deer in headlights you've got an early
call tomorrow I do I've got so much
dialogue in my head it's like wait a
second yeah I'm glad you didn't just
start spitting lines from like me too
and we're all bad it's like we gotta cut
this although all of you now have
designed Wes thank you a question oh by
the way thank you for introducing me
Stephen King books and that world and
everything things oh dude I am so glad
Stephen I am I'm a [ __ ] is that the
right way so like I don't do the horror
so much and yet I worked on Castle Rock
which is all about Stevie King and
horror but I might my way in was I read
all the [ __ ] that didn't scare me so
like I I know how it works
even if
unwilling to engage with like I'm not
gonna Tommy knock anybody like [ __ ] that
no I'd like to sleep well my dad showed
me a bunch of scary movies when I was a
child and he would pause them like
predator he pause it just as someone was
about to die sometimes he was a little
too late
cuz there's VHS um and then he would
explain it was fake and it was all like
makeup and all this stuff and anyway oh
yeah and then we'd watch it your dad
loves you like you watch the thing
swatch the thing ah
you could have paused it now learn some
[ __ ] well [ __ ] thanks dad
but thank you for your question come get
some [ __ ] one more person when I ask a
question
ma Shan what do you want no I didn't got
above him I know I got I got a good one
maybe I don't know there's no price
first of all thank you so much for
writing that for my son
he'll be delighted and you know I don't
know if you know how hard it is to
delight a fifteen year old it's not this
it's not as easy as it used to be I mean
you just give them an iPhone right right
well it's too late for that
an old iPhone again I got you an iPhone
6 that's not even that wouldn't even do
it hate you dad slam leaving but my
question for you guys is like from you
from writing alphas all the way back to
that you back to you know Battlestar
even before that but we'll go Battlestar
what did you do then as an actress and
as a writer that you would never do now
or that you just what have you learned
what's what's different now when you're
taking apart when you're writing what if
what have you learned what's different
my worst working mistakes your rookie
mistakes things you would never do now
but you did then oh my god so many
I found the answer like I got to be up
at five o'clock in the morning yeah oh
my god
Zig around amun um so my mind's pretty
easy because I started when I was like
17 I was like a kid and I honestly
didn't realize how hard it should have
been and how blessed I was that I was in
the right place at the right time and
started working and I wish that I could
go back and take it more seriously
younger I mean I worked just on one
series with with Richard Dreyfuss I
worked with Richard Dreyfuss Marcia Gay
Harden Peter O'Toole Eli Wallach and
Johnson holy [ __ ] we daily just daily
and I was you know 20 or 19 years old
and drinking every night partying my ass
off and coming to work and me and like
Peter O'Toole from what so I you know
Lawrence of a drug lords of what I don't
watch black and white oh wait that's
color sorry oh it was remastered though
we shake it though some gene Simmons
level shade it was bad he thought it was
funny we got drunk off Kosmos one night
Wow I'm trying to imagine what Peter
O'Toole drunk on cosmos must be like
probably like any afternoon all right no
that's that's that is a solid solid
answer Katie thank you um thank you I
think I used to have this tendency in my
first writers room my alphas which I was
broken up very quickly of pitching a
problem without a solution or like
spotting a problem like you know it's
super easy like you know what that
doesn't work for me and and and they
sure would be like
yeah but a my show be if you don't
you've done work for you what would you
do instead and the you know it's almost
volcan of the like you know it's easier
to destroy than it is to create the job
is to create and so to get in there and
like you don't like it fine pitching out
like even if that's not great you got to
come with something you got it like
because spotting the problem does it's
nothing fixing the problem we're finding
us to a way on the path to fixing the
problem you're fixed doesn't have to be
the right one but it might spark
somebody thinking of something else and
something else and then the the
avalanche of ideas can be triggered by
the worst idea but you've got to have an
idea it's the the pitch don't [ __ ] rule
and and I think that going forward in in
most things in life be if you have a
problem great what's your solution to
that problem and and I told it to Trisha
when she like listen I can't make it
tonight but I I asked Katie if she'd
fill in no she didn't ask me I was
implying certain generosity she she told
you right but she's like are you okay
and I'm like Trisha like I would have
loved you to be here and I've been super
fun
Katie's lovely it'll be great but you
had a problem and you also brought me a
solution and that means more to me then
you know because most people don't do
that
so it it it is being additive to the
world as opposed to being destructive to
the world and if you can figure out a
way to do that in all parts of your life
then all the better
but yes making [ __ ] up is definitely
crucial to be like no you gotta bring
something don't come to the table
empty-handed so now now carnival row
you're like I don't let's do this
instead it's yeah I mean it's and and
and that's the job like the job is is
calibrating yourself to your showrunners
tastes and then giving him what he wants
and what he doesn't know what he wants
giving him options for what he could one
here is the the center menu of nine
different things that you could choose
from and that's that's the gig it's
there's making [ __ ] up for a for an
occasionally wayward and fickle boss
he's like I don't like blue today
all right well I guess we're not doing
blue I feel funny it's not a comedy sir
make me laugh no I don't do that I can
give you a car chase though that's good
though that's a that's a really
important thing though because there are
so many people that can do what we do
and we would be delusional to think that
somebody can't do what we do and that
the opportunities we are in in this
present moment are so we're so blessed
to have them and I think that being
being the person that constantly tries
to be better and constantly is on their
game and coming up with solutions and
finding you know the solution to the
problem is the guy that keeps working
you know I'm never I'm never not mindful
of the fact that my life is ridiculous
mmm you know and that there's there are
a thousand left's that I could have
taken there's a thousand [ __ ] bullets
out of the blue that could have derailed
it but like the the road from there to
here is impossible to navigate and there
was no way to plot a course for that and
so to realize that I am here but for the
grace of whatever is valuable yes and
also never take it for granted and also
never let them take you for granted
because you didn't make that yeah you
got there
oh yeah that's true that's a good one
that's one of the things I used to do a
lot you know when I first started in
this business I was so young and I was
trained to be seen not heard and so I
never spoke my mind because I was so
terrified I would get fired or I would
be labeled as difficult or that can
imagine that oh my god well so I didn't
say anything I sat back and the first
time in my life that I actually started
having an opinion that was listened to
was on Battlestar and Eddie cause Eddie
forced them to listen to all of us and
Ron Moore said what do you want to do
you know this character better than I'll
ever know her tell me what okay you
don't think you'd be in this scene great
go home like you would know more than we
would fine
and that was the first time that I
actually started speaking up for myself
so I wish I would have done it sooner
yeah I mean it's I I say it online
sometimes I've said it before here my
credo if I ever had one my family crest
would say be humble but let
[ __ ] know when you are on 33
I'm gonna make you a [ __ ] stamp just
gonna tattoo it right there oh my god so
they can see it when I walk away I
understand like I'm blessed to be here I
understand how improbable it is that I'm
here 3,000 people in the world get to do
this job
400,000 people in the world are
qualified to do this job 10 million
people in the world want to do this job
and I get to do it I understand how long
shot that is understand how improbable
and ridiculous it is but I'm still
pretty good at it oh yeah you know and
like it's not by accident that I get to
do this and so I will never [ __ ] brag
I will never do that at home like I am I
am terrible to live with all the time I
hold my trophies in the mirror
all right guys no ladies and gentlemen I
think that's the end of the show tonight
have you had a good time wait have you
had a good time
[Applause]
there we go I would like to thank so
desperately Katee Sackhoff for coming
out tonight and playing with me for
coming as far as you can and and make it
as rich with all kinds of [ __ ]
awesome ideas that we're not gonna go
sell to Netflix behind the bar
productions we are behind the bar
productions if anybody steals those
ideas we have proof
[ __ ] you you watch the thing on the
youtubes once we're all gonna get we're
also gonna get sued for me humming the
peanuts tune clearly trying to make
money in the wash well yes thank you all
for coming out we're not back next
Tuesday but the Tuesday after that on
December 3rd Phil Lamarr is gonna be my
co-host and it will be my birthday show
yeah my birthday is not on the day but
it's just after the day and so I know I
might buy everybody drinks that night
it's [ __ ] so if you want to come take
a tour on sale come and get drunk with
me and we'll talk about an air [ __ ] but
until then thank you for coming to black
man beyond discover Villa Cantina my
name is Mark Barnard and that is Kenny
sack up come back books week Saints that
time say if that channel SModcast
outcome or youtube.com slash Kevin Smith
good night everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you